good morning believe nation today's
message is don't worry about problems
now over to Chuck Norris is that true
you don't worry about this
no because it doesn't do any good thing
is to say you worry about a problem so
here worrying and all the stuff also the
problem solved all that anguish for
nothing you know the thing is worry
doesn't solve the problem and actually
hinders the problem what you've got to
do is try to find ways of solving that
solution and or that problem finding a
solution for the problem and if you do
then then you know you don't have time
to worry about it
you're able to live by that oh wow
believe me up you know if from the book
as you know I've gone through a lot of
ups and downs that people see strictly
my success but they don't know where I
came from a kid who grew up in the back
hills of Oklahoma
it was totally non-athletic and I won
the world karate championship and the
kid who was extremely shy in school
who'd never even had never even done a
high school play or a book report now
I'm doing this the thing is you find
formulas you find things that will help
you work for what you want so what do
you think I think it's easier said than
done but I agree that looking for that
solution is a great way to go I work in
television so they constantly tell us to
have a thick skin but sometimes you just
get that email or that death threat and
it does finally get to you it actually
reminds me of something I saw from
another celebrity Keanu Reeves something
I saw on LinkedIn and he said everyone
behind me needs to just stop and enjoy
life and I thought all right
Keanu that's very easy for you to say
making millions of dollars a year one of
the few lucky people able to pursue the
passion to a huge degree everyone behind
you they're still making their way
through life they've still got 9 to 5
jobs to finally pursue their business
goals it's easier said than done and yes
Chuck Norris is wise clearly but it's
not always easy for us to implement
especially if the solution isn't
anywhere in sight but I like the mindset
and I like the fact that he's also
saying don't dwell don't
consume yourself with something that
isn't necessarily going to have that end
in sight yeah I agree it's a it's a
simple philosophy and one that I try to
stick to too but it is easier said than
done
I think the thing that helps me is it
attacks me most I think when I'm when
I'm lying in bed like when the night has
kind of calmed down and went to bed and
I think of something and the key they'd
be an idea not even just a problem like
an idea of something I want to do or an
email I need to send out and I used to
fight it and usually I can forget about
that just try to sleep and it's a bit
like tossing and turning tossing and
turning and now I'll just get out of bed
and try to solve it right like I'll send
myself an email or that I'm thinking
about somebody else I'll send them an
email and it's just the release of the
burden that the thing that I think
stresses me out at least the most is
feeling like I want to do something but
I'm not doing anything and when I've
taken some action towards it then it
helps relieve some of the pressure
the thing that I've taken on more and
more recently which caused a lot of
stress in my life is taking on other
people's problems more than my own where
like people that I'm trying to grow who
not not just people the honest but like
people entrepreneurs that I'm working
with and I want to see them grow and I
see them be no play up here and they're
still down here and I like I'm trying to
make them climb and fight through all
the limiting beliefs and their mindsets
and habits and all that and it's not
going as fast as I want and there you
know resisting or like they're
frustrated and I embody those stresses
and problems and and that stresses me
out and I've had to learn to kind of let
that go a little more I feel like a
stress attack and too many people that
I'm trying to help out we haven't
written my own problems I think just
being able to take action on them I will
stress out thinking like I'm gonna
forget you know if I don't have
something to write it down and forget
that idea and then I'll stress me out
just thinking about it
so yeah taking some action and I I agree
and first of all you always find the
positivity to everything that's why I
want to surround myself with you that's
probably why you're a therapist to so
many friends as well it's a great thing
but I think also time makes a big
difference you may see something
completely that can't be solved or that
is perceived to be impossible give it
another day give it another day and you
may come closer to some type of
conclusion or at least something that
you can improve so the question of a
today
is inspired by you what was someone
else's problem that you inherited that
slowed you down I like it I like it
we're going deep leaving the comments
below we'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of in spresso